so we launched on june 10th and our  target was a million pounds  and you know as you do you cross your  fingers you were the first doing this we  thought hope it works um of course we  had faith or we wouldn't do it and then  19 days later after 60 day campaign had  begun  we smashed through the target um last i  checked we're at 1.7 million  uh that's divided amongst uh 550  investors so  i can't do the mathematics so quickly  but it's roughly what 3500 or so uh  you know average investment  but there's a curve there and so there's  a large chunk actually over 80 people  that have invested 10 000 pounds or more  and those those people are entitled to  the challenge black card which aside  from the burritos yeah exactly aside  from the 8  annual interest rate they also get a  free burrito per week during the life of  the bond  we haven't done a deal with a single  bank manager we now have 550 running  around the city so you know the pressure  is on us now to make sure we deliver